in the last video we learned that there
are a class of stars called Cepheid
Cepheid variables and these are these
supergiant stars as much as 30,000 times
as bright as the Sun is a mass xx as
much as 20 times the mass of the Sun and
what's neat about them is one because
they're so large and so bright you can
see them really really far away and
what's even neater about them is that
they're variable that they pulsate and
because their pulsations are related to
their actual luminosity you know if you
see a Cepheid variable star in some
distant galaxy you know what it's
luminosity actually is if you were kind
of at the star because you know you can
you can see how its period of pulsation
and so if you know it's actual
luminosity and then you can you know
obviously it's apparent luminosity you
know how much it's gotten dim and the
more dim its gotten from its actual
state you know the farther away it is so
that's the real value of them what I
want to do in this video is to try to
explain why they're variable why they
pulsate and to do that to do that what
we're gonna think about is is doubly and
singly ionized helium and just to review
helium so neutral helium let me draw a
neutral helium neutral helium's got two
protons it's got two protons two
neutrons two neutrons and then two
electrons and obviously this is not
drawn to scale so this is neutral helium
right over here
now if you singly ionized helium you you
knock out one of these electrons and
these type of things happen in stars
when you have a lot of heat easier to
ionize things so singly ionized helium
will look like this it'll have the same
nucleus two protons two neutrons one of
the electrons gets knocked off so now I
only have one electron and now you have
a net positive charge so here let me do
this in a different color this helium
now has a net charge we could write one
plus here but if you just write a plus
you implicitly mean a positive charge of
one now you can also doubly ionized
helium if the environment is hot enough
you can doubly ionized helium and W
ionizing helium is essentially knocking
off of both of the electrons so then
it's really just a helium nucleus it's
really just a
nucleus like this this right here is
doubly doubly ionized helium now I just
said in order to do this you have to
have a hotter environment that it has to
it has to be a hotter environment in
order to be able to knock off both
deselect this electron really doesn't
want to leave I'm to take an electron
off of something that's already positive
is difficult you have to have a lot of
really pressure and temperature this is
cooler and this is all relative we're
talking about the insides of stars so
you know it's hot this is a hotter part
of the star versus a cooler part of the
star I guess is the way you think about
this still a very hot environment by our
traditional everyday standards now the
other thing about the doubly ionized
helium is that it is more opaque it is
more opaque which means it doesn't
transmit doesn't allow light to go
through it it actually absorbs light it
is more opaque it absorbs light it
absorbs light or another way it absorbs
that light energy that energy will make
it even hotter so that's just something
to think about now the singly ionized
helium is more transparent this is more
transparent more transparent it allows
the light to pass through it so it
doesn't it doesn't get heated as much by
photons that are that are kind of going
near it or through it or whatever it
allows them to go through it here the
photons are going to actually heat up
heat up the ion so let's think about how
this might cause a Cepheid variable to
pulsate so assuming that Cepheid
variables have large or large enough
quantities I should say of these ions we
can imagine that when a Cepheid variable
is dim so let me draw a stim Cepheid
variable so I'll draw that I'll draw
that like I'll draw this in a dim color
so this is a dim Cepheid variable right
here it's dim state in its dim state
just like this you have a lot of you
have a lot of the doubly ionized helium
you have a lot of doubly ionized helium
in the star at least kind of the outer
surface of the star doubly ionized
helium and so this does not allow a lot
of light to pass through
so this is the dim part of the pulsation
of the Cepheid variable now because this
doubly this doubly ionized helium is
opaque it is absorbing the light it is
getting heated it is getting heated it
is getting heated and because it's
getting heated it'll cause the star to
expand so because it's getting heated
the the it'll become more energetic and
the star will actually expand the star
will actually expand now as the star
expands because this doubly ionized
helium is getting heated what's going to
happen the further away you are from the
core of the star the cooler it gets so
this expanded because it was getting
heated but then because it expanded the
outer layers of the star become cooler
and since they're cooler helium won't be
doubly ionized anymore it'll it'll start
to get a couple of it'll get an electron
from each helium atom can now get an
electron from from the plasma I guess we
can say to become singly ionized helium
so now we have singly ionized helium we
have singly ionized helium and now the
star is going to be more transparent
it's going to allow more light to pass
through it so now this is the bright
part of the pulsation it's going to
allow more light through so now it is
bright the star is bright but what's
happening now because the light is no
longer or it's not being absorbed as
well by the helium when it was healy
when it was a doubly ionized helium now
it's letting most of the light or a lot
more of the light get through it's not
going to get heated as much and so it
won't have the kinetic energy to kind of
keep pushing out to keep moving outward
and so it'll collapse back into the star
and so then this will coat this will
cool down and collapse back in and when
it collapses back in what's going to
happen when it collapses back in when
these helium atoms get closer to the
center of the star to the core of the
star they're going to be heated again
their because they're closer now of the
core and when they get heated they're
going to become they're going to become
doubly ionized so then we have doubly
ionized helium again doubly ionized and
then the cycle will go again
is now opaque it will now absorb more
energy that'll cause it to have more
kinetic energy to expand once it's
expands it'll get cool again and
transparent and bright and so this is
the current best theory of why Cepheid
variable stars are variable to begin
with it's this whole notion of having
the doubly ionized helium versus the
singly ionized helium in in kind of the
outer the outer the outer layers of the
star itself